saying that that i don't have enough
willpower well you know no one has
enough willpower the problem with
self-control is at first we need to
identify that there is a problem okay we
need to identify a conflict then the
second challenge is doing something
about it once you realize that this is a
behavior that you want to change
i yell at fishback welcome to the show
thanks for having me excited to be here
today given the fact that we are midway
through march now
how many people do you think have failed
at their new year's resolutions by this
point
uh
well uh we have the data from last year
um i would say
about
a quarter
maybe a little bit more so it's not true
that everybody ditched their resolutions
uh that's just not the case but uh
many did and by november we expect both
people to drop the resolution so by then
we expect only like 25 percent to still
do it till the end of the year i'm
surprised that
75 of people are still holding on in
march i would have thought they would
have been more of a drop off by then
well i i don't i don't know about this
year i know but like the previous data
that we looked at
and let's say they didn't lose hope okay
they are still doing it okay they are
still
trying they are probably not doing as
much as they plan but who doesn't
what determines whether someone sticks
to a resolution or not
intrinsic motivation
that is
how much it feels good at the moment it
feels right okay they
enjoy doing they excited doing it and
and it's a bit surprising because the
reason we set a resolution is not
because we enjoy doing it okay like we
we set a resolution not because it's fun
to do we don't set to eat more ice cream
and watch more tv in 2022.
uh we set a resolution that is something
that's important for us and
for most people in america that would be
health related goals so that's about 60
of their resolutions uh then the second
one is anything related to finance like
getting a job sticking to my job saving
more money and
then we have a few and others these are
not necessarily the things that people
are excited to do because it's fun
and nevertheless what predicts is
how much it feels good at the moment
that you pursue that resolution
wouldn't that mean that it's basically
impossible to complete a resolution
which wasn't fun in the moment
uh yes that is uh unfortunately the the
case now it's you know some some people
set really short-term goals good like i
you know i need to uh
do some medical checkup and yeah you can
do that even if it's not fun okay you
just
go there and you do it and it's over
but this is not the typical resolution
the typical resolution is to eat eat
healthier food or to exercise more and
if it's not fun
that's not going to work
what have you looked at between
a focus on process versus a focus on
outcomes or goals because when james
clear brought atomic habits out whatever
three years ago or four years ago i
think everybody thought right this is it
i'm just going to focus on the process i
can have growth without goals you know
you do not rise to the level of your
goals you fall to the level of your
systems how true has that been borne out
in the psychological literature
so you need a goal okay if you don't
have a goal then you don't set a
resolution in the first place if you
don't know that you want to eat
healthier food okay or exercise more
then you'll never get there
and by the way we recently found that
the extent to which people are
extrinsically motivated the extent to
which they are
they are motivated by the uh the goal
and by setting a goal that is more
long-term and that also predicts whether
they will set another goal next year
okay so these are the people that are
gold driven that have these long-term
destinations
and
it's important to have i would not drop
that it's just that it's not enough and
often the process matters more than we
think but definitely start with the goal
how do you define the difference between
intrinsic and extrinsic motivation
a good question
intrinsic motivation is doing something
as its own end okay that it feels right
at the moment the purpose is not
necessarily to reach the destination but
to
enjoy what i'm doing uh right and now
extrinsic motivation is the
prize by the end guys what i get from
completing the goal from being done with
that something
now the truth is that for the goals that
we care about they are never 100
intrinsically motivating right the you
know
what like what a walk in the park on a
nice day is only intrinsically uh
motivating okay like a dinner with a
loved one is only intrinsically
motivating but no one sets these goals
okay we would do this even if we didn't
plan
uh what uh people said to do which is a
career or you know
hobbies that require work okay like
exercising uh
saving money and
and so on
these are
goals that are somewhat intrinsically uh
motivating and the little that they are
really uh matters a lot so you know to
give you an example
uh we found that when we made doing math
for kids more intrinsically motivating
that is they were doing math while they
were listening to music and we bought
them
pencils with all kinds of colors it was
kind of fun to do and this is research
with caitlin wooley at cornell by the
way
what we found is that they were sticking
with this longer now did we make
math class intrinsically motivating for
many kids not really only slightly more
intrinsically motivating than it would
have been otherwise
do you only just need a little edge then
a lot of the time
yeah
yeah and you need to update that right
so we know that people stick to their uh
workout
if they find something that they like
but what i liked yesterday
might be boring today okay or maybe the
weather has changed and what was fun to
do outside yesterday is not fun to do
today and so we constantly need to
adjust with a focus on how do i pursue
my long-term goals such that they are
right for me that they feel good at the
moment
it seems to me that there's a attention
or a
trade-off at least a little bit between
somebody in a planning mode where
they're looking at what do i want to do
longer term what's the direction that i
want to go in perhaps even what are the
steps that i would need to go through to
get there and then an executing mode
where you're just kind of following the
plan and working for the boss that was
you a couple of days ago or a couple of
weeks ago is that is that something that
you've noticed as well
yes and it's interesting there is a a
lot of work in that psychology on on
these two uh phases okay yeah uh some of
the work
uh this is by peter golvitzer and when
you uh talks about
being in that deliberative mindset where
you deliberate your options where you're
kind of objective you see what's
possible for you versus the implemental
mindset and the implemental mindset is
like now you are the contractor that you
hired to do the work that
the the liberator uh decided to do it
and now you are much more like focus on
doing the thing that you are not really
evaluating the alternatives very
carefully and there is work on assessors
versus locomotors
some people are just more assessors in
in their personality and this is
something that eric blansky at the
university of maryland studied
they like to assess they like to
consider should they do this should they
do that like what are the pros what are
their calls they are giving you like
these complicated tables they
don't necessarily make a decision they
think about it and then other people are
locomotors okay they just move ahead and
to the extent that they are extreme on
locomotion then often they don't assess
enough okay they just
go through the motion without really
thinking is this the best
uh thing for me and so you kind of need
the right balance between assessing
and moving and locomoting have you got
any idea about the optimal
phase length
for going from
uh
assessing to locomoting or from planning
to executing
three months
six months one week
it really depends on the goal right
uh if it's uh your morning exercise then
probably five minutes is plenty of time
to decide what you're going to do and
then it really doesn't matter just like
do something okay
i if it's your a career choice and
you're going to make this decision in
five minutes uh
i i would say uh
don't okay and and sleep on it and be a
a bit open to uh not having closure or
not having a decision until you really
thought through your options and so
you know sometimes we encourage people
to think more before they do sometimes
we just say you know
do it okay
it doesn't really matter how just do it
overall you've done a lot of work to do
with motivation both psychologically and
then in uh experiments plus all of the
other work that you've been looking at
what have you found that people get most
wrong when they're thinking about
motivation
oh
people are getting a few things wrong
um
let me mention a couple
okay uh
one is that
people think that
they should
change themselves
but it's actually better to change the
situation
okay it's actually harder to change who
we are and change our personalities
compared with changing that
the environment in which we operate
okay and it is really easy to
eat healthier food when there is only
healthy food around you and it's really
hard to do it otherwise it's
really easy to work when you're
surrounded with colleagues that are
supportive and willing to help and it's
almost impossible when you are
in the wrong place with the wrong people
that are not uh helping you
and and so people often have the naive
perception that if i just want something
strongly enough then it will happen and
then they encourage themselves to just
like
do what you need to do and then like
really try harder and and often it's
about removing the barriers designing
the environment that works best for your
goals
uh
the second mistake that i will mention
is that
people believe that their future self is
going to be a
a much better person than their present
self in a way
the future self is going to wake up
early in the morning and do everything
that they should during the day and
their future self is not going to be
tempted by you know the social media or
certain foods and so on and
and not showing empathy to your future
self is is a mistake it's like planning
to drive many hours when you get up in
the morning and you're fully awake and
not having
sufficient empathy to the person that
you are going to be after
three hours of driving we just can't do
that anymore
there's a um there's a term in japanese
called revenge bedtime procrastination
have you come across this i i am curious
uh so it's it's a word similar to like
sharden freud or whatever in german
that's just something that we don't have
a concept for in english
and it's called revenge bedtime
procrastination which is kind of the
reverse of not having enough empathy for
your future self it's having too much
disdain for the person that you were
earlier in the day so you haven't
achieved what you meant to earlier in
the day so you punish yourself by
staying up at night in an attempt to try
and like get stuff done but then all
that you end up doing is making tomorrow
morning hell for yourself and then you
kind of continue this cycle i've
certainly noticed with myself as well
that
you do have this sort of superhuman
prediction about the person that you're
going to be in future especially when
you're setting goals just have this
presumption that all of the
inefficiencies that you have in your
system are going to be pushed out of the
way by the sheer volume of goals that
you create well if i make enough
crushing goals then i'm going to have to
squeeze all of the inefficiencies in my
20 minutes on youtube here and my extra
long walk over there and i'll make sure
that i
get to work on time and stuff and it's
just not the way that it works i have a
friend chris sparks who's a productivity
expert and he has a term where he says
in order to pick something up you have
to put something down what he means by
that is that
it's safer to presume that your current
level of output is the level of output
that you're going to be at when you try
and achieve this goal as well as opposed
to
presuming that you're going to be this
superhuman incredibly resilient much
more effective version of you that might
happen but probably not
i i love that the worst advice that i
think i ever got was that if you have a
lot to do just wake up one hour early
okay and it's the worst advice because
as you know if you wake up one hour
early you also go to sleep one hour
early you really don't make more time in
the day by
doing that you're just more tired
why is it so hard to choose a goal like
when people actually have to try and
come up with something that's good why
is it so difficult for them to do that
i don't know that it's hard it's it's
hard to set goals right and to set
the right goal for you it needs to be
a goal not a chore okay it needs to be
something that
you like to do okay that you enjoy
thinking about the destination and not
necessarily that uh you know you think
about all that the hard work that is
involved and
to give you an example
do or approach goals work better than do
not goals
because do not goals feel like a chore
okay and it's really hard to do this
thing that i set up
not to do i mean not to do the thing
that i set up not to do what's an
example of that
so that uh you know and not uh
to a smoke
not to uh contact my ex
and not to have certain thoughts like
the classic study by dan wagner was to
ask ask people not to think about white
bears and guess what once you ask
people not to think about white girls
there is nothing more that they want to
do than thinking about white birds okay
it's really like not thinking about your
ex or trying to push a tune out of your
your head the more you try to do it the
more this thing comes back to your mind
uh because how do you know that you are
successful you check yourself you check
yourself by bringing it back so all
these feel like sure there is also
reactants okay when i tell myself that i
should not eat something
i really want to eat that just because
it's now being and i identify as the
thing that i should not be eating so
these goals tend to be like chores
now even like
concrete goals like you need to be
sufficiently abstract to motivate
yourself if you think about your goal as
a as a saving for a house this is less
motivating than buying a house or you
know applying for a job is less
motivating than
getting a job
and so people often set their goals such
that it's not that motivating adding
targets is helpful and often people have
very vague goals so you know if i tell
myself that i want to
exercise three times this week or i want
to finish a certain project by the end
of the month this is better than
i want to be
successful at work or i want to work out
more and people don't always get this
incentives can
be wrong for your goal okay setting a
goal that doesn't fit with your
incentives that
uh
doesn't work very well and then
intrinsic motivation we we actually
started they are setting a goal that is
important but horrible to pursue
that
is not going to work
the difference between
approach and avoidance goals i want to
do something and i shouldn't do
something
there are things that we don't want to
do anymore and we do want to make a goal
out of not doing them anymore so what's
a better way to reframe let's say that
somebody wants to stop smoking or spend
less time on their phone
how should they frame the goal of
spending less time on the phone or of
stopping smoking
ideally in terms of what you want to do
instead okay and for the fun that is
actually easier than uh for uh quitting
smoking uh for the fun is that you know
when do you
use your phone too much
okay uh for many people that would be a
before bed uh or when i wake up what can
you do instead
okay so have your goal to read a book
before you fall asleep and not and not
look at my phone before i uh fall asleep
that is much more likely to uh
to happen
uh for a quitting smoking this is harder
for people because it's really
hard to find like what is the thing that
that is the opposite of not smoking like
what else can i put in my mouth okay
like people often you know when they try
to stop drinking soda they replace it
with water okay they just put something
else in front of them so they can
consume that thing instead
uh and and then one thing that people
can do is uh
i think about these situations in which
they they smoke and
what can you
do instead in that situation that is fun
that is a rewarding that's going to make
it
a pleasant time without
smoking
it seems to me that boredom
must play a little bit of an important
role when it comes to what we're talking
about here because if you need to
replace doing something you don't want
to do
with another thing that you do want to
do the fix is always doing something
it's never that you're allowing yourself
to have space within the day
i suppose that you could say i'm going
to sit on the couch and not look at my
phone but there's going to be a fair bit
of friction and temptation in doing that
so yeah it feels like very much an
active process of trying to do a thing
instead of doing the thing you don't
want to do anymore
uh yes and
and i like this example like imagine
like sitting in front of your phone
trying not to use it like yeah
that doesn't work for anybody right uh
so either you put something else in your
hand that you do want to do or you you
know you go outside okay you do
something else you just don't sit there
on the sofa so you you don't have this
opportunity to
uh want to spend too much time on on
your phone
or your phone is not there
and and then again you know you you
change the situation okay if you want uh
your child
not to be on the computer or you take
away the computer or if you want
yourself not to be on on your phone you
take away the fun
are there um biological predispositions
toward differing levels of motivation
probably so
but it's unclear that uh that they are
that important and they say probably so
because we see that some people
just have more grits okay they're just
more motivated they're just more able to
uh pull through
but we also see that
often there is a lot of variability
between domains so you you might be uh
an amazing
at work okay but and not so good when it
gets to uh controlling your consumption
of junk food
okay and my i might be a very health
conscious uh but uh terrible at saving
and so
we see that these
differences which suggest to us that to
the extent that there is like this
general factor of that more motivated
person
it doesn't explain everything
it is the case that the the self-control
for example is getting
better with age okay um oh is that right
you get more self-control as you grow up
uh yeah until they until later okay
until it goes down again
um
when that when you get better or when uh
um
so beyond like it
into your 20s you are still getting
better so the teams and and like people
in the 20s are still at their
improvement and part of it is just a
controlling uh uh impulse
um and no
older people are
just generally less
tempted they have better control and and
then i took i can't remember the age for
the
the older uh
people's
studies but that they
if i remember correctly it was something
around 70 but i mean i i say this and i
you you hear my voice goes down because
i'm not i i like if someone says no like
you've got the age one like i say well i
guess so
i would say that it's also unclear when
self-control goes down whether people
are less able to inhibit
or they just don't care i that was what
i was thinking that older people just
don't give a [ __ ] anymore that might be
that might be
yes i i you know i i tend to agree i
think that that's a large part of it
it's just like whatever you know i can
say whatever i want i
spend enough years here yeah
yeah um so that's an acute motivation
and setting goals and stuff how can
people ensure that their drive doesn't
slow down after this first honeymoon
period
um yes
it depends on the on the goal again and
for some goals actually there is an
increase okay in particular when you
think about it all or nothing goal the
more you do the more motivated you are
so if they take four-year college
about half of the
people that start college will drop out
and they usually drop out in the first
or the second year so they give
it's harder at the beginning and and it
makes sense that your last year in
college is getting you a college degree
your first year is only getting you the
a quarter of a college degree and so you
you see the people work harder uh or
stick to their goal more toward the end
same for also loyalty problems by the
way consumers drop them at the beginning
when they are just one purchase away
from the reward they are not going to
drop the program
uh so for some goals you see that there
is in increasing uh motivation uh even
you know animals uh run faster
as they get closer to the rewards
whether it's food or you know for for
your dog seeing you they will run faster
as they get closer to you
for
other goals you see that there was a lot
of enthusiasm at the beginning and then
it
it slows down and if there is end you'll
see again an increase in in motivation
uh but you you'll have the middle
problem and um
and
uh this is when uh you are no longer
excited about the beginning you're no
longer excited by the end it's just the
long stretch of the middle
uh
we looked at it in one study this is we
there we matured hillary uh in israel
where
people were lighting the candles on the
menorah and like they had to do it over
the holiday of hanukkah for eight
consecutive nights many people were
lighting the menorah on the first night
eight days later eight nights later many
people were lighting the menorah again
on the last night in the mill ah not
so much
so people
cut corners in the middle uh people do
less of
good work
what to do keep middle short okay a
weekly exercise goal is better than a
monthly exercise goal okay monthly
saving goals is better than an annual
saving goals
short goals have short middles
so you're looking at
creating progress markers along the way
that allow you to hit those bit by bit
by bit even if you're then going to
repeat it again for the following
week or month or whatever
exactly and you nicely identify that
when i say like a short goal well you
know it's not if you have a weekly
exercise goal is not it's not you don't
just do it for one week yeah
you want to exercise again next week but
that's another goal that's the goal that
i'll have next week yeah so you wouldn't
say uh i want to exercise 150 times this
year you would say i want to exercise
three times every week
yeah
okay yes because if you think about the
number of times that you need to
exercise this year
huh well um i've seen
studies around the
finishing
times for people in
marathons
and how they all bunch together around
these totally are essentially totally
arbitrary numbers right you like you
have loads of people that finish between
three hours 58 and
four hours or two but no one finishes
very few people finish it like four
hours ten or something they'll they'll
push for the next particular milestone
yes
i love this study this is a study that
shows how effective targets are
uh once you uh you know you look at the
the tradition of marathon times you see
that there are so many that are doing it
in under four hours compared to just
about four hours and you wonder like is
it easier to run a marathon in three
hours and 59 minutes than four hours and
one minute no
right it's really like the the idea that
if i can get it under my
set goal which for many marathon runners
it's four hours or three and a half
hours or four and a half hours
uh then
i achieved my goal okay in a way
anything that is below that
like specific time is is a win and if i
have like one minute after four hours
that is seen as a loss and we don't like
uh losses but i would say that there is
a problem with that that if we are too
uh attached to these numbers that we put
to motivate ourselves we
we might end up cutting corners okay we
might end up
[Music]
maybe pursuing the goal not in the right
way
and let me give you a couple of examples
first is i i caught my son who's 10 year
old waving his hand
in the evening trying to get his feet
paid to get to the number of steps that
he was hoping to have and i bet he's not
the only person who does that
right so you're you want to meet the
girl but not really in the right way
and the other example comes from uh
wells fargo who a few years ago had what
they called the great initiative
and that was a program designed to sell
every customer eight financial products
so the great was gr8
um
as you can imagine or as you might
remember from seeing it on the media uh
that
did not
go well
the only way to get customers to have
eight financial incentive is by
selling them
sorry eight financial tools is selling
them tools that they didn't need
uh or often were even unaware of so as a
customer you you were just paying for
financial tools that you didn't know you
you owned goodheart's law in that way is
so vicious i see it in myself as well
right that you you
posit yourself uh
a an outcome that then becomes a measure
and then all that you start trying to do
is hacking the version of the measure
that you wanted to do like purposefully
not drinking much water the night before
your weekly check-in on the scales
because you know that that's going to
make you well no no
i know that i said i wanted to lose
weight every week but
i didn't mean i just wanted to have less
water in my body what i actually meant
was that i wanted to lose body weight as
opposed to just fluids so yeah you
were so
sneaky and tricky in that way and
another thing is that when we have
dashboards and analytics which are
increasingly being given to us right in
the modern world you can very quickly
create an outcome that becomes a measure
and you can start to optimize for the
thing that you think is what you
actually want the example i always use
is with mailing lists so somebody could
say um i'm giving a hundred dollars to
everybody that signs up for my mailing
list and they get a million people sign
up for the mailing list but then they
don't give away the million dollars so
they may have achieved their goal of
getting a million people onto their
mailing list but that wasn't actually
the goal the goal was i want a million
people to want to sign up to my mailing
list who feel like they're connected to
me who genuinely want to receive my
messages with goodwill and don't hate me
and aren't sending me loads and loads of
complaints like that's the actual
outcome that they wanted but because we
synthesize things down and we're able to
look at dashboards we see things in a
lower resolution way
and that causes us to try and shortcut
our own rules
absolutely okay and these are all the
ways in which our targets can backfire
can lead us to pursue that the wrong
goal if there is a shortcut we should
suspect that we are going to take the
shortcut case so instead of eating less
food you might drink less water
to get to their desired
weight on the scale
uh
and and so we really need to be
thoughtful in setting these targets and
realized that the only purpose to set it
in the first place is to get people or
ourselves to to pursue their the goal
another problem that you didn't mention
with targets is that we
we tend to feel so bad when we miss out
okay and so if you know many people have
calorie target uh and if they just miss
it by a little bit then you have the
what the hell effect which is like well
today is one okay or the wick is void
now
this is completely like in your mind
okay that you you really
like that
the food that you are going to eat now
has the same impact on you than you know
the food that you ate before you you
missed your target but
you kind of gave up on yourself because
you you didn't quite meet your very
optimistic
target is there a way that people can
reframe that catastrophic mindset
uh
there should never be a what the hell
effect
okay uh it is never a reason to uh
to lose it just because you lost it by a
little bit okay it should never be a
reason to i just you know yell at your
your friend or partner uh because you
were already yelling okay all right
you know give up on yourself in in any
other way and i in in my research i
talk about
what your actions signal to yourself is
it a signal about your commitment or a
signal about your progress
okay and
in this like what the health situation
people
take their their failure in this case
the fact that they couldn't do something
as a signal that they that they are
uncommitted that they just they can't do
it okay it's like whatever okay i'm just
like uh not doing it
if instead you take it as a signal of
low progress or lack of progress
then what you need to do is just try
harder and make more progress
what role does feedback have in this
uh feedback is uh is critical for
pursuing our goals okay we need to know
where we stand
we need to uh
be able to look at ourselves or measure
it somehow or have our friends and
mentors and bosses and colleagues tell
us how we are doing uh so feedback's
critical the thing is that it is much
easier to learn from positive feedback
than from negative feedback
and
we miss out on
a lot of great information that is often
in
negative feedback how can we become
better at taking negative feedback then
uh we need to realize why it's hard
it's hard emotionally that's actually
pretty intuitive it's also hard
cognitively
okay it is easy to ignore negative
feedback because often what negative
feedback tells us is what not to do and
now we need to do the mental
switch
it creates an avoidance goal for us
which we then need to flip into an
approach goal exactly
right like so instead of you saying um
one of your bosses comes up to you about
a meeting that you've been in and says
when you get nervous in a meeting you
look down at your hands and it doesn't
look very good to the group of people
that you're trying to present to you
then need to do the work of when i get
nervous i need to look up at the board
or i need to fix my eyes onto somebody
as opposed to just taking it in that
this is the thing that i do and then
obsessing over the fact that you look
down at your hands when you get nervous
i love this example
i i'll tell you why because i i got the
feedback before that
i don't look into the camera in
no zoom or skype
calls and the first thing when you hear
this feedback he's like uh why why do
you say that do you know how hard it is
to look at the camera and look at the
person the person is below the camera
and and really what you need to do is
like the mental switch where you know
instead of looking at the person look at
the camera okay
and so instead of looking at your hands
uh no think about what you need to do
look at some something else and this is
not easy for for people by the way
animals cannot do this at all okay when
you are
a yell at your dog the dog has no idea
what is the correct behavior or just
that what they did was not something
that you appreciated
so people are a little yeah that's it
that's interesting so the dogs don't
really have very good inference
they they can do
avoidant or they can do approach but
they probably can't turn an avoidant
into an approach exactly
exactly when you yell at your dog that
they should not do whatever they did on
your carpet
they don't realize that the correct
behavior is to go outside and do it on
the grass
okay
you'll have to give positive
reinforcement for that behavior because
that
the punishment didn't do anything
that's really interesting so is there a
is there a case to be made around um
parents raising children or also
training animals
that you need to see
if you want to try and have motivation
to do things that you want them to do
you need to almost look at
your feedback in two different pathways
one focusing on approach and one
focusing on avoidant
yes and it is
much easier to learn from positive
feedback now this is not to say that we
cannot or should not learn from negative
feedback we should
because they there it happens
we take the the wrong way and we can
infer the right way by the fact that we
took the wrong way
uh and and so not learning from that
would be absolutely a mistake
you know even more than that sometimes
there are many right ways and only one
wrong way okay like maybe all the dishes
in this restaurant are amazing except
for one that is bad and so really like
annoying that this is bad is
much more useful than
knowing that everything else is is good
and so you you need to be able to learn
from negativity but i agree with what
you said and i know i write about it
that if you're trying to teach someone
the using positive feedback so much
easier for them to learn
what was the study that you did with the
improv class
oh thank you uh so you know i
said before going back to the beginning
of our conversation uh that we are going
to stick to goals that feel good okay
that if you feel
good when you're doing it you feel right
then you're going to to stick with it
uh but
often
what is going to feel good doesn't feel
good when you just started a and
improvisation is one of those things
when you just start improv
you're mainly going to feel embarrassed
and uh when we we partner here with the
second cd improvisation club in chicago
uh we studied
just regular people okay not
professionals that are going to uh take
an improv class and we approach them in
the very like first few
classes so they'll just
beginners
and at this point we tell them
you know your goal for this exercise is
to uh
feel bad okay is to feel uncomfortable
we find it
uh and when people had the goal to feel
uncomfortable
they were more motivated they wanted to
come back they actually spent more time
on the exercise they were taking more
risk so the exercise required them to
not move in an interesting way and they
were more willing to like move their
body and like make kind of voices and
and so on
uh because they were more comfortable to
feel uncomfortable that was their goal
and so embracing the discomfort is often
a way to initiate some habit
later on it will be easier that's like
preparing yourself for kind of
realistically what's going to happen a
difficult medical procedure an
examination that you know that's going
to be hard or whatever i guess kind of
warning yourself about that in advance
helps you to be prepared
it's it's you know it's warning and i
think warning helps with self-control
it's even more than a warning here
because if your goal was to feel
uncomfortable now that you feel
uncomfortable you know that this is
working
okay
it's like having your goal to sweat
while you exercise
like you most people don't like to sweat
okay i don't like to sweat but no it's a
sign that this is walking okay that i'm
doing it right okay and so you don't
want the pain-free exercise
and
it's so you know it's more than like the
preparation it's uh the signal in
feeling uncomfortable changes
that's really good i really like that so
talk to me about people don't just have
one goal right it might be easier if
life was just a singular track and all
that we were focused on was eating the
right food or starting the business or
the good relationship or whatever how do
people juggle multiple goals
yeah right it would be really nice to
want
one thing but unfortunately
unfortunately we need to pick our
battles and
and decide between several goals and
the first thing is to decide whether you
are prioritizing or
seeking some compromise or balance
if you are prioritizing then you want to
put one goal above others okay maybe you
want to put your your health goal above
uh
eating whatever you want whenever you
want to
uh
often self-control kicks in okay and we
can talk about that uh when
you balance so when you seek a
compromise now you you think about let's
say like work and family how do i fit
them together
uh
how do i find activities that pursue
several goals simultaneously we call
this in psychology multifinal means okay
they're like
they're defeating two birds with one
scone
um maybe i can bike to work so that i
get my commute and exercise at the same
time okay maybe uh
i can i find that the food that
is is tasty that's the most important
goal for people when it gets to eating
but is also healthy and not too
expensive and it doesn't take too much
time and so on and organizing
your life such that you identify these
activities that help you achieve
multiple goals is often uh critical
and then i can talk about self-control
and like prioritizing yeah well
willpower and self-control i think is
what a lot of people
blame
downfalls in motivation on i certainly
know that i do right that it's
especially i guess with avoidance rather
than approach goals but with that too i
i didn't go to the gym today it must be
because i don't have enough willpower or
i ate the food that i said i wasn't
going to eat it's because i don't have
enough self-control
uh yeah and this is uh
not a great attribution to have okay uh
saying that that i don't have enough
willpower well uh you know no one has
enough willpower okay like so let's just
not count on the uh willpower uh the
the problem with self-control is at
first we need to identify that there is
a problem okay we need to identify a
conflict we need to identify that this
uh one morning in which i uh don't
exercise matters okay or you know one
doughnut matters or the one time i yell
at my partner matters
uh and then the second challenge is
doing something about it once you
realize that
this is a behavior that you
you want to change
for the identification part it helps to
use what we call a wide decision frame
that is thinking about several decisions
together
okay uh what uh
should i do if i consider losing my
partner not losing not losing my partner
god forbid losing my temper every time i
yell at my partner
uh and
nowhere
what comes to my mind here is actually a
study about
financial decision making
uh with abby sussman my colleague here
at the university of chicago and
she asked people how much money they
are willing to spend on kinda
exceptional expenses like going to a
hotel room or not buying champagne like
no buying a gift to a friend
and she either asked them about one time
or all the times that they will want to
do it this year
and as you can imagine when people think
about all the time that they would like
to buy a gift to someone this year then
they they are more financially
responsible now all the time that i will
stay in the hotel room this year
maybe i should not spend so much money
than if i think about it just
uh once
um
you know going back to my temper
example all the time that i'm going to
be
tired and
and be tempted to just lose it
when it gets to resisting the temptation
that has been identified
what we find is that it helps to think
about it in advance to anticipate it and
you get this mental preparation it's
like
you know i use the metaphor of preparing
to lift a heavy box if you know that
he's going to be having you
mentally and physically even like with
your body approach it with more force
if you know that this is going to be a
tense situation at work or that you're
going to
be tempted to stay in bed in the morning
and not work out if you anticipate this
in advance we find that you're better
able to
do something about it uh when when the
time comes
what's happening when you watch a
motivational youtube video
on the internet you know you watch some
compilation of some guys lifting heavy
weights or being really healthy or
living some cool life or it's tony
robbins shouting at you through the
screen
what what's going on with regards to
motivation there
so these are two different examples
when you watch uh
athletes
i don't think that anything is happening
you're just impressed by them you don't
want to exercise by yourself okay when
you watch
really successful people doing the thing
that they do really well
this is
not doing much uh when you watch someone
who wants you to be successful
that's different that is a role model
and that
can be a motivating now you you need to
perceive that person
as wanting you to be successful
and if it's a friend or family member
someone that actually knows you and
really want you to be successful that's
easy
if it's a person
on youtube then
you you know you need to make some
inferences here that this person
actually cares about you
uh
and
you need to notice uh
to what this person values so it's not
usually so much about their actions as
much as the the values that these
actions uh convey if if you will so
we'll give you yeah go ahead to give you
an example like no
the products that we buy online let's
say with youtube the the videos that we
watch on youtube are videos that
other people liked
not necessarily that other people
watched we are much more attentive to
the number of likes than the number of
people the the number of times that the
video no way
uh yeah
uh right so we we follow
what other people value more than what
other people do
that is very interesting are there any
other examples of how that shows out
shopping
we are we look at a number of stars and
not a bestseller
it's often not even easy to find
information on
how often people buy this product we we
really care to see how
much the people that bothered rating
this product liked it that's what other
people liked not what other people do
yeah yeah and with products i i think
that is often a mistake there is often
more information in what people do than
well yeah because a lot especially with
products less so with entertainment but
with products people can buy things for
a utilitarian purpose they don't
necessarily i don't
love my
dishwashing brush right but i bought it
and i would happily buy another one but
i'm probably not gonna be bothered to go
and give it five stars on something so
you have a little bit of a selection
effect here for what are the products
that people are emotionally invested in
exactly right and so you must find that
there are the amazing reviews for this
very special
product it's not really
like meeting
what you need to do
what so you've mentioned there that
motivational videos you kind of need to
infer that the person that you're
hearing from has some sort of connection
with you or is speaking to you in some
way that suggests that there is a big
social element to how people can use
motivation what's the social support
structure
uh pathway that helps us to be motivated
so we are social animals uh we do things
with
other people and in the presence of
other peoples for you know some goals
and i would argue our important goals we
do them with others okay we have
projects at work with others we
do things with our neighbors okay we
start a family with someone or some
people okay that that help us
and and so we really want to see that we
have the right company that we can do it
together that we know how to divide the
work such that we don't have a huge
problem of uh social loafing
other goals we do in the presence of
others and so we
we care for
what is in fashion and what other people
say is is a worthy
uh what is appropriate we just pay
attention to others and then
on top of like like these two ways in
which we walk with others
we also form relationships based on our
goals we are attracted to people that
help us facilitate our goals and people
are attracted to us because they
see us as supportive
of their goals and so our goals our
motivations very much are the basis of
our uh relationships
what about actual relationships between
people i had a guy called adam lane
smith on the show a few months ago and
he was saying uh
vasopressin bonding between uh men and
women is problem solving so he talked
about how women heavily bond through
oxytocin but men bond quite heavily
through vasopressin so you have a
problem the man wants to feel useful
honey can you help me open this jar of
beans or whatever and the guy comes over
and he does a thing and that's bonding
because
on average men like to be involved in
things and women like to be involved in
people so that kind of made a little bit
of sense to me but presumably goals and
admiring your partner's ability to
pursue and
chase down their goals both individually
and as a pair that must contribute to a
successful relationship
yes a successful relationship require
that you need each other okay that you
are instrumental for each other's goals
and relationships that
do not survive when uh
you are no longer instrumental for each
other you are no longer
facilitating
each other's
goals and you know sometimes people are
aware of it and they do
take joint projects for the sake of
being instrumental
for each other
other times
people tend to be more aware of how much
my
partner and needs to support my goal
then how much i need to support their
goals we actually we have
we we recently uh
collected data from people asking how
much
you know your partner and how much your
partner knows you and
in general this is already documented
and phenomenal people feel that they
know everybody more than everybody knows
them okay so uh there is dashimity where
i feel that i i know the people around
me
i am more of a mystery to them
but what we recently found is that what
predicts relations relationship
satisfaction is
how much
you feel that you are known you feel
that the other person in your life
knows and can support your goals so the
little that you give them credit that
they actually know
matters a ton why do you think that is
because this is uh what makes them
useful for your motivation what makes
them instrumental for your goals and
this is really the
the basis of the the social bond that uh
we will work together that we will do
something together and you know there is
a
way to say that sounds a bit selfish
like we're just looking to to use other
people and i
and i don't want it to sound
like that
we born to other over looking for help
with our goals and willing to offer help
with with their goals we work on
stuff together and if we realize that we
can be just more
thoughtful in how we we make sure that
we invest in our relationship that we
have good relationships yeah i think if
someone had a problem with the idea of
being helped or using their partner to
assist them with their goals
that is under the presumption that the
goal of a life is to live the most
comfortable least encumbered sort of
existence that you can which isn't the
case right we you know you look back on
over the last year look back on the
things that really really mattered to
you the things that probably mattered
weren't super easy it wasn't that day
when you woke up and everything was fine
and there was no challenges and you
didn't overcome anything no like you you
take value from the times when there is
difficulty that is hard and you lean
into it even harder and you come out the
other side and things go well so
what the thing that was in my head there
is you're talking about couples and
projects is how many of my friends have
decided to renovate the house
with their misses
and
i hesitate i'm not sure how good that's
been for some of their relationships
because based on like the feedback that
i've got from them
some of those projects have nearly
destroyed the relationship but i
understand that if you were able to
manage the project a little bit better
it might work
yeah well renovations don't have great
uh reputation
but
but you know it's something that we do
a as a couple and uh and and no i love
this example i would just ask any uh
couple uh what uh what do you need to do
together okay why do you need each other
okay what uh what's your next goal and
maybe you are saving for your vacation
maybe you're planning your vacation
maybe you're doing house renovation
maybe you're
adopting a pet
uh but if there is uh
if you don't no longer need that person
in in your life uh it is uh very uh hard
to maintain the relationship and so uh
this is when we we bring goals to
support the relationship other than
bring people to support our goals and
both directions work
yeah that's a nice way to frame it i'm
also going to guess that i mean having a
child you know giving birth to a baby is
the ultimate project
you know and it's one that only you and
your partner are usually involved in
it's 24 hours a day
there's a whole bunch of genetic
components and motivations that are
going on as well so i imagine that
aside from the fact that you love your
child and all the rest of it having a
child is a useful project to work
together with your partner on
uh
yes although uh having a child at least
for the no the first period in the
child's life is also an exhausting
project
and and
that constrained the relationship so we
definitely see that uh
you know when when two people that
already were struggling are now trying
to maintain a relationship when they are
both very very tired or at least one of
them is very very tired
uh
that
that's a problem okay there is a
depletion of uh motivation and so
uh you know it's always one of those
instances of what doesn't kill you make
you stronger and a child to their
relationship definitely makes the
relationship stronger but first as long
as that they the experience doesn't kill
the world unless it breaks at first yeah
precisely precisely
yeah
yeah so you know if the only purpose of
that the new goal is to get the relation
the relationship to be stronger well you
know adopt a cat
don't go for the kids straight away is
the first one to try and fix the
relationship okay yeah well that's
that's good advice
uh what was the study that you looked at
to do with
was it a signed book inside of a tote
bag that talked about sort of degrees of
freedom away from
something
thanks for mentioning that uh this is a
study that
was
designed to test how
much people are averse to invest in
means like we want to work toward goals
we want to
work with something that is that is
important that is useful we don't like
to invest in minister we don't like to
pay for parking or shipping or gift
wrapping we don't like to study for
pre-requisite classes
what frankly shady and i
did
uh
was
inviting our mba students to submit bids
on
a colleague's book
and in
one condition that is one group of
people they were submitting their bids
on the book okay they saw the book and
they were telling us how much they are
willing to pay and another group of mba
students were
bidding on a tote bag that contained
that same exact book and they knew that
okay like they saw that the toy bag in
the book and we told them that they are
submitting bids on the tote bag but
whoever gets the bag is also getting the
book so
the first
group has uh an inferior deal okay
they're just getting the book the second
they get a book and a bag
but
the first group was on average willing
to pay 11 dollars more than the second
book
than the second group
basically the first group was paying
23 on average for the book and that uh
the second
group was willing to pay 12 dollars for
a tote bag that contained
the book in economic terms that means
that the value of the tote bag was
negative okay it was a negative 11
that makes no sense
uh what's going on here
makes psychological sense people don't
want to pay for a means they don't want
to pay for a bag but they are willing to
pay for for the book
uh and this is a nice illustration of
how in life we often willing to invest
so much more if it's the thing itself
then if it's a way to to get there
what's a more direct example about how
this would be applied to our motivation
um so you know i talked before about
setting your goal as a as having a job
not as applying for a job
as getting the thing that you want and
not as a as the way to uh to get there
setting your goal in as a destination is
something that is exciting and something
that you you want to uh
achieve and not anything that is on the
way there
and uh you know some examples that we
specifically studied where uh you know
studying for something that is really a
means
to something else people were not
interested in the materials very much
people didn't want to buy products that
they will use in order to get another
air product so
just define your goal in terms of the
the thing itself not the way there
that runs counter a little bit i think
to some of the ways that people have
framed process goals
over the last couple of years again like
the whatever the aftershock of atomic
habits has got a lot of people very
focused on the process as opposed to the
outcome um and yeah we are fighting
against this this means versus
actual goals thing i wonder how many of
the goals i set this year
are poorly framed in that well i know
for a fact that i've done avoidance
goals instead of approach goals
and
you know replacing that with i want to
use my phone less versus i will read for
45 minutes on an evening time
that's
it achieves the same outcome
but it's framed in a much more active
and proactive way and also it makes you
forget about the phone
yeah and i i agree it's it's a nuanced
point here when i say so let me try to
see if i can explain it in a clear way
like
we definitely want to set a goal that is
exciting to do okay that is not just
exciting to achieve that is exciting to
do and so
i if i'm excited about
you know aerobic exercise
and
not so excited about running then
setting my exercise goal in terms of do
more aerobic and
and not more running and that's uh
that's the way to go
but
if i set my goal too
concretely okay too much on on the level
of the the means uh then i
i don't have the vision okay i don't
have the aspiration i don't know why
uh i'm doing it so no if i tell my son
your goal is to take do your
this is not motivating as uh
your goal is to
to learn math okay your goal is to uh
like read books and understand them and
the way we are going to do this is like
through this like homework
uh assignment but
ultimately like
if your goal in life is to do your
homework that's
just not inspiring that's just not you
know
this is like paying for a tote bag it's
not it's not the thing okay it's just
the way there
i yell at fish back ladies and gentlemen
if people want to keep up to date with
the stuff that you do where should they
go
uh they should get my book get it done
and they should check my website
ieltsfishback.com
and they will see all the ways in which
they can
connect with me and i would be excited
to connect with them so you know thank
you so much for making the introduction
my pleasure what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace